everybody what is going on welcome to
the 18th Python with tkinter and
building an actual fully fledged program
tutorial video in this video we're going
to be adding the last of the menu items
to our menu I'm sure some of you guys
are tired of doing menu items
hopefully I've sparked you know spice it
up a little bit with some functions that
they're running but the more extra
exciting stuff is coming after these
last menu items so I'll be happy to be
done with them anyways so let's go ahead
and get started so we're going to come
over to our CF EDC app class which is
here and we're going to make changes in
the typical spot which is between the
last major bit and TK TK config I'll
come down here and now we're going to
add the following we want to have a
trading button so this is going to be a
button that the user can like go to
trade and they can click buy or sell or
do manual trading and my idea is that
eventually we could allow them to set
preset amounts so say they have one
total Bitcoin you can trade you know
point 0 1 Bitcoin at a time if you want
so you can buy and sell point 0 one at a
time so maybe you want to set up preset
offers and say ok when I hit by just
automatically by point zero one Bitcoin
for market let's say and then the user
could literally just click one button
and execute that trade for them at
market value okay and the other thing
too is we can bind them to key presses
so control be instantly buys and ctrl s
would typically be saved but we could
bind it to something else but you get
the idea um you can allow for really
quick buys and sells and then also we
can have a manual trading and the manual
trading is going to be quite a bit
different than the other stuff that
we're building and that's kind of an
interesting part of this application
because that's going to pull up a new
window and that's also where we're going
to incorporate a module into our program
so so far our program is like one really
long script and that's not really the
most ideal because it's a project that
only I am working on it works because
it's
I mean that's making it but in general
you might have multiple people working
on a project and generally like most
large applications are going to have a
lot of imported modules from other other
places so people work on different parts
so to speak
anyway um let's go ahead and started so
we're gonna say trade button equals T ke
dot menu so it's a menu option menu bar
as usual comma tear-off is going to
equal one and then we're going to go
ahead and have trade button dot ad
underscore command and the label to this
command will be manual trading and then
we're gonna actually have the command
itself equal lambda and then we're going
to do the pop-up message and that will
be just this is not live yet something
like that in the current version on
github
this manual trading is not live however
I do have a working version of that so
maybe very soon that will be live but
we'll see about that so we've got that
now we're gonna do we've got basically
manual trading then we want to have
automated trading and that's going to
allow the user to trade say say that you
know a lot of people trade on really
really simple rules like when a simple
moving average when the ten simple
moving average crosses over the twenty
if that's up you know if it crosses over
an upward motion by and if it crosses
over in a downward motion sale so we can
allow people to actually fill in
parameters for their automated trading
and the program will trade based on
those so that's that's to come then
we're going to do trade button dot ad
underscore SEP for rate tour it's a hard
word for me and then here I'm just going
to copy and paste these these right here
and instead of manual trading this will
be a quick buy and this is where the
user can set up a quick buy amount and
then a quick sell amount as well if they
wanted to why might a user want to offer
different amounts for buying so there
are fees taken out of every trade so on
btc-e it's a point zero two point two
percent fee so so even general in
general you would want to buy a certain
amount and sell a lesser amount because
on top of that amount you have a fee so
if you trade the exact same amounts
every time you're going to pay a fee and
so you come to incorporate that in so
you know people might have a different
version of a buy and sell anyway you get
the point
um then we're going to add another
separator and have another option here
so we'll do this copy paste so these
here will just be the actual actions
right they're going to quit you know you
click quick Buy and it just executes by
you click quick sell execute to sell
instantly for you at the values that you
preset now how might you preset those
values well you're going to have to set
up your quick buy sell easy enough and
then that's basically all we need to add
for that so we're going to do mini bar
dot add underscore Cascade the label
here will be trading and then menu that
we're going to basically add to our menu
bar is going to be trade button so it'll
be this little you know value up here
that'll say trading you'll click on that
you'll have options like manual trading
automated trading quick buy quick sell
and setup quick buy quick sell easy
enough and then next we want we have a
as we've seen and maybe if you've toyed
around with the application whenever the
application updates first of all it
refreshes the graph so if you have
zoomed in to the graph when it does its
update it's going to zoom you out of the
graph and that might be not ideal to you
so you might want to actually pause the
whole animation function same thing with
the algorithmic trading we're going to
attempt to throw everything
into the animate function so maybe we
want that to stop animating for some
time so we want to be able to have start
and stop so the next thing we're going
to have is start/stop literally and
that's going to equal T KDOT menu and
then it's going to be to the menu menu
bar and tear off equals 1 and then we're
going to have start/stop dot add
underscore command and the label for
this command is going to be resume and
if they do resume the command will be
equal to lambda a function that we don't
have yet but we're going to call it load
chart and the parameter will be start to
that and then we're just going to copy
this what we just typed here copy paste
and this one will be we'll go we'll call
this pause and load chart will call stop
and that's that now we're going to go
ahead and add this um we type out this T
lower case that T hopefully you didn't
copy me there but that was a typo
now we'll do menu bar dot add underscore
Cascade label the equals uh resume pause
client and the menu that we're going or
basically the menu that we're adding
here is start stop start stop like that
now finally most major programs have the
following as their last menu item and
that would be a help so this one has a
help and it's got about idle and it's
got idle help in Python Docs so we want
to have a help help as well so we're
going to call help menu easy enough
equals TK dot capital M menu where's it
going menu bar tear-off is going to
equal 0 I don't really see a pointer
enough help then we're going to help
menu dot add underscore command the
label to this one will be tutorial
so that's going to be an interesting one
so the idea of tutorial which will be
probably are going to cover the tutorial
function in the next video but the idea
of tutorial is going to be that we can
lead the user through an interactive
tutorial on how the program actually
works so that'll be kind of interesting
to do I've always liked really
interactive tutorials so I'd really like
to add an interactive tutorial to the
program and doing so I'll show you guys
how we can have sequential windows I was
having kind of a hard time with that at
first but it's not too hard so anyway to
commanding this tutorial and then we'll
also have menubar we'll just leave
tutorial for there and that will be the
only option minibar dot add underscore
cascade label equals help and the menu
will equal help menu might also add like
a help option or like a frequently asked
questions or something like that or
something that links to a Wikipedia page
or a wiki about how this application
works something like that for now we'll
leave it this way um and that's it okay
so we've got all of our options now what
we want to do is a real quickly we're
going to add this load chart function
it's a really short function so I'll put
that in this video in the next video
we'll talk about these tutorial
functions that's a little bit longer so
let's go up all the way to the top and
now we're going to define a new function
and it's going to be load chart camel
cased and the parameter is run basically
start stop and then we're going to go
ahead and global a parameter called
chart load which does not exist yet so
let's go ahead and make it chart load
and we're gonna call this um actually
chart load will say true we'll define it
as true naturally so global chart load
and then we just basically ask two
questions if run equals start chart load
equals true so basically chart load is
animation
pretty much enemy so it's actually
really not just chart load as we move on
this will be what pertains to the
algorithmic trading section of the
program all that stuff and really
probably eventually we will separate the
two because in general if your audit
Bureau you're doing automated trading
you might not necessarily want to load
the graph every time something like that
but then again the graph if you're doing
automated trading generally you're going
to need that data anyway so I don't know
we'll see what we decide to do about
that but eventually we'll we'll create a
headless version of this program so
people cuz right now it's a GUI so if
you wanted to run this on your own say
on a cloud server say you want to host
it on Linode calm and or digitalocean
this won't run on there because it wants
to run a GUI and you know the program
will fail immediately so we'll make a
headless version as well that people can
run off of a Linux machine on the cloud
and they can do automated trading pretty
much indefinitely but way down the road
so now if for an equal start L if run
equals stop will do chart load equals
false okay let's go ahead and save and
run that really quick and ok we did get
an error tutorial is not defined that's
fine let's just define tutorial really
quick tutorial empty parameters pass
that's just a really quick way to to
make a function we wrote ok so here is
our application file exchange data
trading they could do all this stuff we
click on this you get the window it says
it's not live yet ok that's fine
resume pause resume look I want to
capitalize those and then help and
tutorial which is not live so we've got
all that done the only thing I really
want to do we need to capitalize resume
and pause that just is going to bother
me so let's go do that really
really quick where are you here we are
so capitalized and applause okay okay so
that's going to conclude a tutorial
number 18 for our tkinter video in the
next tutorial what we're going to do is
build this tutorial function so the one
that we just really wrote really quickly
and just made it pass we'll fill that in
and actually kind of we're not actually
going to make the full tutorial the the
program is not done so there's really no
point to make a full tutorial but the
idea is to kind of make a simple
skeleton for how we might do this
tutorial so that's what we're going to
be doing the next video so stay tuned
for that if you have any questions or
comments please feel free to leave them
below otherwise as always thanks for
watching things for all the support and
subscriptions
until next time